you
hi I'm Dan Perrault I'm here with
Evander Holyfield and we're talking
about his new documentary champs I gotta
do boxing because how would it be to
bury the film covers a lot of people who
grew up and struggle a lot of the
greatest boxers came from areas of great
struggle is that personal hardship
motivate you to succeed further well it
did because the fact of the matter is
that we we were on welfare and my mother
did tell me and she said son I'm poor
you not she said if you don't make the
same mistakes I made you know you ain't
got to live in this environment I was
poor for you to be rich when I came from
the mud picks in my life which is just
in a big ball of confusion cuz I didn't
know what to do because I all not know
that I had a lot of money and I'm a
fighter
and I want to think that I want to do is
fight I really don't want to be
responsible for all this but it was a
part of it I want to talk about Tyson a
bit because he was obviously a major
rival in your career you said that you
watched every single Tyson fight was
there anything from watching him that
you were able to learn and incorporate
into your own game well he the only
person that I ever considered worked
harder than me because I try to do the
things that he did and I hate Nance I
can't do it that way he was the expert
in all the things that they do it a lot
of people thought that it's all about
this brute strength did it happen but I
realized that my mother told me good
fighter and you can't wish them away
because they don't go nowhere you had to
face it now the film touches on some of
the darker sides of boxing the fact that
there is no union like other major
sports they do this one does not have
one it doesn't have like great long-term
health provisions what do you think
needs to change in the sport box
it definitely neither you need to come
in in some formal way and make it a more
beneficial to the fighters and you know
different hair plans and stuff like that
the fighters really given himself and
and everybody making money and then when
it's all over the fighters don't have
been
I'm sure that it should be some kind of
pitching plan for fighters you think the
world of fighting sports in general need
to change it has changed drastically
over the last 15 years but in terms of
you know fairness you have such a
difference and wealth from the top
boxers to the bottom and you don't about
thinking I don't want to take that from
them guys that who work harder than
everybody because you know everybody
ain't meant to get the thing if you
don't you don't do the same thing I know
well you're gonna penalize a guy who who
great and he put all the time and
everybody else went with the head dates
and did all these things a night with me
I didn't I go home I didn't get a chance
of data I didn't get a chance to go to
prom the problems a lot of things that I
didn't get to do but when I became to
heavyweight champ in the world it was
all worth it